happy birthday kimberly
look at you you're 40 and all grown up
you look beautiful just like when you
were a little girl
i watch over you and your sisters and
brother and the kids
every day talk about the ultimate
birthday gift
kim kardashian celebrated her 40th
birthday with her closest
friends and family and thanks to her
hubby kanye west
that included a visit from her late dad
robert kardashian i
am so proud of the woman that you've
become
kimberly and all that you've
accomplished all of your hard work and
all the businesses you have built
are incredible the most impressive is
your commitment to become a lawyer
and carry on my legacy it's a long and a
hard road
but it's worth it and i'm with you every
step of the way
the reality star revealed that the yeezy
designer gifted her
a hologram of robert who died of
esophageal cancer in 2003
just two months after he was first
diagnosed
he was just 59 years old sometimes i
drop hints that i'm around
like when you hear someone make a big
pifi
or when you make a big pea fee pretty
sweet right
also is anyone else wondering what the
price tag was on this gift
something tells me it wasn't cheap
the most beautiful thing that i have
witnessed is watching you grow your
family
and since the gift was from kanye the
hologram of mr k
also gave a big shout out to well
kanye you married the most most
most most most genius man in the whole
world
kanye west and while some commenters
were quick to hate on that line
most fans gushed over the gift i always
know his heart and so did kim
the kkw beauty founder called it the
most thoughtful gift of a lifetime
and a special surprise from heaven
tweeting quote
it is so lifelike we watched it over and
over
filled with emotion keep doing what
you're doing kimberly
you are a beautiful soul know that i am
very proud of you
and i'm always with you kim double down
writing quote i can't even describe what
this meant to me and my sisters my
brother my mom and closest friends to
experience together
thank you so much kanye for this memory
that will last
a lifetime it's been so much fun to be
on this journey
with someone that just brings you on
this like whirlwind
of a life that i never dreamed that i
would have so
it's been a lot of fun the keeping up
with the kardashian star who turned 40
on october 21st
marked the occasion by taking her
friends and fam on a tropical vacay to a
private island
she shared a bunch of pics from the
getaway on social media
noting that everyone quarantined ahead
of time and was tested before they left
but naturally the gathering sparked some
backlash from fans who found her post to
be insensitive given the fact that
oh you know we're in the middle of a
global pandemic it was such a beautiful
experience and i
want kim to focus on just how beautiful
it was and what she did for everybody i
mean
i don't want that to overshadow but
kim's little sis chloe shut the haters
down on the ellen degeneres show
this year is a frustrating year i get it
i think there's
so many frustrations going on for
everybody
but also it's her 40th and this is
something that she really wanted to do
for us it was such a nice thing some
critics expressed concern for the staff
who had to serve the group
but the 36 year old reality star said
there was nothing but love
and appreciation from everyone they
encountered
so many people said that we were their
first party or guest that they've had in
months and what it's done like for them
to be able to pay their bills or to do
stuff for their family i mean just
hearing those
yeah messages when we were there was
really we felt really good and we felt
so safe